for years actually decades Buffalo
Public Schools have been paying for free
cosmetic surgery for their unionized
teachers hi I'm Nicholas B with reason
TV and today we're talking with Kyle
Olson he's the founder of the Education
Action Group which looks at school
spending in conjunction with budget
problems and actually a school district
outcomes Kyle thanks for talking to us
thanks for having me you know what's the
one sentence mission of EAG eajy is
looking to expose school spending where
the dollars are going what's being
taught in the classroom and what unions
are doing the role that unions are
playing in public schools it's been
around for about eight years what
prompted you to start it
I was seeing what was going on in
Michigan schools and how unions were
picketing and threatening to strike and
they were fighting about health
insurance and spending and all of those
sorts of things and so I came to the
conclusion that the students were not at
the center of the equation and so I
started EA G as a way to kind of expose
that and bring attention to it I think
you're right that students are rarely
seem to be at the center of school
equations or discussions so who are the
other bad actors in that school boards a
lot of times either because of
ideological reasons or they back down
from the from the union's administrators
testing companies contractors the whole
purpose of this project in this exercise
is to say there is a lot of money flying
around the government education system
and why don't we actually look at where
it's going first before we decide it
whether or not it needs more so recent
sorry
Buffalo schools spend 5 million dollars
on free plastic surgeries for teachers
what's going on there this is probably
one of the worst examples of school
spending in the country so for years
actually decades Buffalo Public Schools
have been paying for free cosmetic
surgery for their unionized teachers and
that's through their insurance ball
through their insurance probably the
policy they have what's called a
cosmetic rider
decades ago firefighters and the police
were under the same contract as the
teachers and I think a strong argument
can be made if you're in the line of
duty a police officer or firefighter and
you are harmed in the line of
dooty you should have a cosmetic
procedure that's covered but what
happened was the teachers and the
firefighters and police broke apart
their contracts and the teachers kept
the cosmetic-surgery Wow okay you have
one here school districts in San
Francisco spending millions on white
privilege training for employees it's
one of these efforts intolerance where
the school districts are saying we have
this black versus white achievement gap
which is legitimate you look at the data
it's legitimate but the conclusion that
they've come to is they're saying the
education system is built and is geared
towards white people and the black
students can't relate to the white
teacher and so we have to do this
training for the teachers so they
embrace their their white privilege and
they come to understand it and that's
what will fix things and so we're seeing
these school districts that are spending
tens hundreds of thousands of dollars on
this white privilege training but what
they're not looking at is this going to
improve outcomes for children and if
it's not we shouldn't be spending that
dollar and so they've been doing these
trainings for years but they don't
actually look at the outcomes to decide
whether or not it's making any
difference here this one blew my mind
Milwaukee schools spent millions to
maintain vacant buildings and among
other things it's the Milwaukee School
District has the fourth highest per
pupil spending rate so what what are
they doing keeping vacant buildings they
have very highly successful choice
schools schools that are in the voucher
program who want to expand their parents
want to send their children to those
schools so these schools are going to
Milwaukee Public Schools that has dozens
of vacant buildings and they're saying
we would like to buy your buildings and
Milwaukee Public Schools is going well
if we sell them that building then we're
gonna lose another thousand students and
so it's a business decision they're not
interested in high quality education for
children what they're interested in is
protecting their turf you know people
talk about sunlight being the best
disinfectant the idea that just talking
about this stuff will create a certain
amount of outrage has that happened or
have you seen in any of the
you've reported results from that of you
know the the people most affected by
saying what the hell's going on here and
sure to burning down the house or some
well I mean we have school board members
that reach out to us and say will you
please take a look at our district which
i think is interesting because I mean
don't you have employees who shouldn't
be doing that it's incredible - to talk
to board members they will say you know
we proposed a 2% raise for teachers but
nobody actually knows what that means in
real dollars the school choice has been
kicking around in the kind of current
form since they since the 1990s it's
growing in leaps and bounds when you
look at voucher programs when you look
at charter schools when you look at
online education when will we reach a
tipping point where it is just what do
we do best for individual kids I think
we're getting close to that I mean when
you look at what happened in Nevada and
in Wisconsin and Indiana and states
across the country that are moving
either towards an ESA or about your
program whatever the policy is it's
getting power back to the parents and
when that happens you know these sorts
of examples that we're talking about the
school can continue to do that can
continue to spend money that way but at
that point the parent when they're armed
with that knowledge they can decide
whether or not they want their child to
go to that school or to go to a
different school that has different
priorities well we'll leave it there
we've been talking with Kyle Olson he's
the head and founder of the Education
Action Group which is online at
dot org Kyle thanks for talking - thanks
for having me for Reason TV I'm Nicholas
bee